[Applause]
hello and welcome to this intelligence
squared debate on the motion that the
West should pay reparations for slavery
the issue of reparations has gathered
momentum and a renewed sense of urgency
in recent years in America senator
Elizabeth Warren who was running for the
Democratic presidential nomination has
blacked reparations for African
Americans and closer to home at the
recent Labor Party conference senior
figure is called for reparations
including the Shadow Chancellor John
McDonald who suggested that one way that
Britain could do this would be through
sharing free or cheap green technology
with its former colonies Cambridge
University has announced that it will
investigate its links with slavery and
how the university gained financially
from it and glasgow university has
become the first british university to
set up a reparative justice scheme
committing to pay 20 million in
reparations to atone for the
university's links to the slaves trade
but not everybody agrees that this is
the best way forward they argue that we
are talking about crimes committed by
and to people long since gone they argue
that the costs would [ __ ] economies
and hurt the people reparations claim to
want to help so that's what we're going
to be debating tonight and so without
further ado let's open up the debate our
first speaker for the motion is Kevin de
Andrews he is a professor of black
studies at Birmingham University a
regular opinion writer for The Guardian
and was part of the team that launched
the first black studies degree in Europe
he is author of Back to Black retelling
black radicalism for the 21st century
his family is from Jamaica and he is a
descendant of enslaved Africans okay
[Applause]
okay so thank you um in 2018 the HMRC it
was it was a Treasury released a tweet
that had a surprising Friday effect now
you may know what this fact was as they
tweeted it incorrectly actually that
millions of you have millions of you
have helped in the slave trade through
your taxation because in and this is
actually incorrect because actually the
slave trade and slavery are different
things which is something lost on the
Treasury and lost on most commentators
on this issue the slave trade was
abolished in 1807 and by the United
Kingdom after the fear of Africans in
the Haitian Revolution slavery continued
for another twenty or so years carried
on what the hates what the Treasury was
talking about in this particular
instance was the abolition of slavery in
the British Empire which did happen in
1833 oh really 1834 and it and your tax
money you will be happy to know merrily
happy to know when in to helping end
slavery but how did it do this it did
this because in order to end the system
of slavery the government paid the
biggest baler in the history of the UK
the UK of the UK economy to the slave
owner they actually paid reparations to
the slave owners a figure so large they
had to take out a loan from the Treasury
a loan that was so big they only paid it
back in 2015
which means that me descendant of slave
my mum descendant of slaves my dad
descendant of slaves and half of you in
the room potentially descendant of
slaves all paid slavery reparations to
slave owners so the principle has
already been established that
reparations are due the question is who
wanted you to know what is still there
the kind of marry celebration of the
Treasury of this fact is that that
wasn't the only reparation that was paid
to the slave owners by the British they
when slavery ended they had a period of
four years of apprenticeship where the
formerly enslaved had to spend ha
of their day working for free for the
slave masters so we had to actually pay
reparations with their own labor again
the principle of reparations is firmly
established it wasn't just this didn't
just happened in the UK Denmark Holland
Spain all paid reparations to slave
owners in fact Haiti as I already
mentioned the price of their freeing
themselves liberating themselves from
France was in 1825 they submitted to a
hundred and fifty million franc debt to
the French in reparation to who slave
owners an amount of money so large that
it took 122 years for Haiti to pay off
in fact one of the reasons Haiti is the
poorest country in the world today is
because IV had to pay that debt off for
122 years so when we talk about the idea
of slavery being something in the past
we are being completely ignorant because
up until 2015 me and you were still
paying off this debt again a debt so
large fire it was represented 40 percent
of the British government's purse at
that time 40% imagine that 40% of the
government's purse and 5 percent of GDP
in today's money that is a hundred
billion parent reparations to who the
slave owners so why I've established
that reparations are will established in
the history of law and went to the slave
owners I could probably stop and sit
down for the next six minutes but I
won't I will carry on and give you more
evidence of wife since I do right so
we've established the slave the slave
owners got a lot of money this money
went to people like me went to the
church he went to government he went to
a company's he went to people like David
Cameron's family and this money still
actually is with us in the economy today
what I really want to stress for you
here is this is not an issue of
something that happened in the past
because the wealth that was derived from
slavery is still with us today so when
we talk about the West the West really
emerges in after 1492 when Columbus
sails the ocean blue I'm sure you have
heard the story which has been dubbed
once upon a genocide after they had
after they had killed 98% of the natives
of the Americas in
needed labor in order to build what
became and it's not a coincidence
America is the leader of the free world
the richest country on the planet it's
because the the founding of the Americas
was absolutely essential to the
development of the West and we whose
labor was it that developed America the
Americas when I say the Americas
I mean North America the Caribbean Latin
America it was enslaved Africans
millions upon millions upon millions of
people taken stolen from stolen from
Africa to do the work for free for 300
years the biggest lie the West will tell
you is that when they encountered Africa
Asia the other parts of the world they
were advanced and because of this
advancement we were able to have
capitalism and what we call so-called
civilization right this is actually
untrue in 1492 Europe was coming out of
a dark age and was the only place on the
planet that had actually was in a dark
age at that period of time Europe was
not advanced in 1492 Europe had to in
vail itself to the eastern empires in
order to get into them and one of the
primary ways that Europe and the West
became rich was through the enslavement
of African people the 300 year cycle of
the triangular trade that generated so
much wealth it accelerated the Western
Western capitalism and built the world
we have today so if we think about
somewhere like like like Britain this
city were in today London London would
be half its size without the wealth from
slavery places like live Liverpool which
was a dock Bristol which was also a duck
before the slavery would probably not
exist in any way shape or form without
the wealth derived from slavery even
places like I'm from Birmingham
Birmingham made the majority of guns and
chains for slave trade and this is
actually one of the ways in which
Birmingham became the powerhouse that it
was and Manchester the cotton industry
the cotton which were so proud of and
the factories up north was again
directly and linked mixing when
Liverpool opened as a slave as a slave
port they built a canal to Manchester
and is only after that the Manchester
trade in cotton because we're was cut
Wade and cotton get derive from slavery
by 1788 there were 180,000 people
working in Manchester on money from the
sleiman of African people so even the
cities we have today the way the country
looks today is built on the wealth of
slavery couldn't exist without it so
this isn't money that has gone away it's
money that is still here
a perfect example of this would be
Lloyd's of London the UK's largest
corporation massive multi-billion
corporation that celebrated its 300th
anniversary couple of years ago CEO was
on television and proudly declared they
were happy to celebrate their roots in
ensuring the merchants trade she
neglected to mention net trade was the
slave trade right in fact whole
industries like insurance like some of
many of our financial products and
financial that made financial capitalism
what it is derived from where slavery
stocks bonds these words are not used by
accident they actually tell you the
roots of where these things come from
Lloyd's of London before it was insuring
slave voyages was a coffee house and it
was a coffee house in London where they
would they would advertise for runaway
slaves so they were the enslaved
Africans in the UK and the runaway
slaves in London would be returned to
where London this is housing in veiled
capitalism and slavery up so when we
thought the wealth is around us you can
see everywhere you can see in these
university spaces you can see it just
walk down the road you can see the
wealth the wealth is still here our
current system is the way it is because
of the money derived from African
slavers
so this case is to the case of
reparations unpaid labor for 300 years
untold psychological and human damage
and reparations again and what I remind
you significant reparations paid to the
slave owners and what did the enslaved
receive less then nothing not even
nothing less than nothing I had to buy
their freedom through work in the in the
UK and to buy their freedom in places
like Haiti and this is a win and when we
think about that time doesn't stop after
the installation of every gonna be where
slavery ends what happens
so Britain my family said Jamaica you
are left with a place in a country which
is built on a plantation economy that's
only this is nothing else there is no
other development
plantation economy you are left with no
nothing nothing to show for your labor
for the last 300 years you are left in
absolute destitute poverty
you're also slavery ends and colonialism
then continue it's not like they just
stopped and ended and finished Malcolm X
has a quote where he says if you stab a
knife nine inches into my back and only
take it at three inches that's not
progress even if you take the knife all
the way out that's still not progress
unless you heal the wound no progress
has been made
unfortunately the knife is still firmly
in our backs right nothing has been done
to redress the balance which explains
why places like Jamaica are
extraordinarily poor which explains why
my family migrated from Jamaica to this
country and experienced racism and still
experience racism today if you want to
understand why the world is the way the
world is why racial oppression is here
in America in the Caribbean and in
Africa
remember millions of people taken from
Africa the impact on African African
economy was devastating what slavery did
was they assured in a world of white
supremacy the creation of the Negro the
idea that I am NOT fully human and can
be used as a beast of burden it created
the idea of white supremacy black on the
bottom white on the top and everybody
else in between and if you look today at
global inequality what do you see Africa
play at the bottom the West largely
white at the top and everybody else in
between the legacy of slavery is not
something passed it is something with us
and there is a substantial debt owed to
those who suffered from thank you
[Applause]
Thank You kindy next up we have our
first speaker against the motion
Catherine bubble sing Catherine is
headmistress and co-founder of mckay dia
community school in london she's the
author of two books including to miss
with love based on her blog describing
her experiences teaching at an
inner-city secondary school her mother
is Jamaican and her father is Guyanese
she is a descendant of slaves slave
owners and indentured laborers well I
don't actually disagree with lots of
what can be said except for his
conclusion of course that reparations
should be paid slavery was an
abomination when if you read about the
terrible things done to slaves it's hard
not to cry but today's debate isn't
about whether or not slavery was bad or
good it's about whether the West should
pay reparations for slavery which West
ought to pay the Portuguese brought the
slaves the Dutch who provided the boats
the British provided the insurance the
Portuguese Spanish and French who ran
the largest colonies and one of the
African people who sold their brothers
and sisters in exchange for guns
allowing them to grow their own kingdoms
then there's Brazil is it part of the
west of the 12 million Africans that
were shipped across the Atlantic Brazil
received nearly 5 million of them so why
are we only discussing whether the West
should pay for reparations for slavery
hard to come up with an answer so let's
put aside the complexities of who might
pay for these reparations and turn our
minds instead to who might be the
specific recipients of the money what I
want to know is what am I going to get
out of this I mean after all I'd quite
like a new car perhaps I could upgrade
my flat and get something nice just off
the corner of Oxford Street and I'm
definitely entitled nursery my parents
come from the Caribbean my mother is
black Jamaican but then my father well
he doesn't really come from slaves
he's indo-caribbean from Guyana of
course his people were indentured
servants when slavery was abolished
Indians were taken to the Caribbean to
take the place of the slaves who had
been freed somebody had to do the work
my father's family
lived in the same Hut's as the slaves
once did were tied to the same families
as the slaves once were just instead of
my father's grandparents being bought
and sold instead it was their contract
of indenture that was bought and sold
and obligated them to work for the time
period set by their owners
the conditions were horrific my
illiterate grandmother might have told
you all about this herself had the
poverty an environment that engulfed
Indian indentured laborers in the
Caribbean not been so grotesque that she
died when my father was only six years
old but I'll forget that story because
my father's mother and their people
weren't slaves and that isn't going to
deliver me the cash is it I'll stick
with my black Jamaican mother not sure
what we do with people like Kamala
Harris one of the candidates for the
Democratic nomination and the US
presidency her mother is from India her
father is from Jamaica her father admits
that his family owned slaves does she
get a piece of the pie Barack Obama is
black but his mother is white and
descends from slave owners like so many
mixed-race people so do they get half
payments instead of full payments how
was this woman to work anyway I'll tell
you one way in which it might work there
are various websites out there right now
in 2019 this is mainly an American thing
where black people are getting white
people to donate money for it to them
you know in the guise of reparations so
I'll read out one of these sites to you
it's a real site run by a black American
woman who right now is collecting cash
from white people because of reparations
owed to her so there are instructions
for black people and for white people
here so for black people in the audience
listen up number one if you were black
and a descendant of chattel slavery
please put your PayPal vem no and or
cash app in the comments of this post
number two you do not have to plead your
case or share why you are participating
being black is enough so black people in
the audience you want some extra money
to go out on the weekend just get your
PayPal information on there now white
people these are the guidelines number
one realizing that you have white
privilege or that you are inherently
racist is not sufficient okay it's not
sufficient to recognize that you have
white privilege today
action that gives your power away white
people so right now think of that action
what's it gonna be number two this is
not a substitute for reparations from
the government this should be every
politicians platform are you demanding
this from them white people are you
writing to your local MP and demanding
reparations number three you can give $1
$5 $10 $50 $100 $1000 $10,000 whatever
works for you
little smiley face so you can give this
young woman ten thousand dollars and get
rid of your white guilt now this young
woman leaves out of the equation that
slavery isn't just black and white the
first point is that everyone had slaves
okay people of all colors became slaves
for economic reasons because of war
because slavery as odious as it was was
simply a normal way of life Arabs were
extracting millions of black afront
African slaves centuries before
Christian nations did for about 13
centuries compared to the three
centuries European nations ran the
Atlantic slave trade Arabs marched
African slaves across the Sahara Desert
and as such they died more often it was
customary to castrate them and many died
from this practice the Arabs also
enslaved over 1 million white European
Christians the term slavery in fact
comes from the word Slav the Slavs
inhabited Eastern Europe and were taken
by the Muslims of Spain in the nineteen
in the ninth century
not to mention that Africans have been
enslaving each other for thousands of
years the point is that slavery the
second point is that slavery was not
about race and it's important it was not
about race the only reason we think it's
about race is because philosophers like
David Hume in the 18th century ranked
human beings and put Africans at the
bottom saying that they had no souls the
Enlightenment imposed the concept of
race on a practice that had been going
on for centuries in order to justify
that practice and why did they have to
justify it and this is the point because
people in the West began to question
slavery's moral validity the fact is the
people of all colors owned slaves both
as part of the Atlantic slave trade and
outside of it in the United States and
Caribbean black people black people
owned thousands of black slaves and so
the Native Americans nearly 20,000 of
the Native Americans Five Civilized
tribes sided with the Confederacy during
the Civil War fighting to keep slavery
alive
28% the black population who were free
in New Orleans pledged their support to
the Confederacy all of the 13 southern
states of the Confederacy had
substantial numbers of black slave
owners there were more than 250,000 free
blacks and nearly 4,000 of them were
slave masters who owned more than 20,000
slaves the practice of slavery was legal
after all we need to remember that
governments did not own slaves slave
owners did in fact the US government
fought a war to end slavery how much
should the descendants of the 400,000
Union soldiers who lost their lives
fighting to free the slaves pay to the
descendants of the slaves they freed
it's bizarre to suggest that human
beings should inherit the outrage of the
deeds of their parents should the child
born from a rapist be branded a rapist
because of his father's criminality
should the child of a mass murderer be
sent to prison because of his father's
crime no in America in the Maine it was
the Democrats who owned slaves and the
Democrats who in the Maine passed and
enforced Jim Crow laws it was also the
Democrats who founded the Ku Klux Klan
should the current Democratic Party be
held responsible for this no we do not
inherit the sins of our fathers aside
from the fact that it would be simply
impossible to make reparations work in
any sensible or practical way one must
ask whether it would be helpful to the
people one is trying to help this is key
so we assume that reparations are going
to help them giving people lump sums of
money does not work economists often
point the george'll and lottery of 1832
in which parcels of land were
distributed randomly what happened to
the descendants of those who were lucky
enough to be given this land are they
the richest families in Georgia no in
fact within one generation after the
distribution of the Georgia land one
could not distinguish between those who
had been given land
and those who hadn't certainly my own
direct experiences of working for
20-plus years in the inner city with
families on welfare demonstrates this
time and time again rather than give a
man a fish it is always better to teach
him how to fish all giving the fish does
is make the giver feel better
reparations might relieve white people
of their guilt but it will do little
else so back to my initial question why
are we only discussing whether the West
should pay reparations for slavery
because while slavery was common to all
civilizations only one civilization
developed a moral revulsion against it
very late in its history Western
civilization not even the leading Marlys
in other civilizations rejected slavery
at all rather than be ashamed as
Westerners we should stand proud for
having led the world out of a mentality
where slavery was the norm and we should
vote against this motion
[Applause]
Thank You Catherine our second speaker
for the motion is Esther Stanford Susie
she's a reparations activist and lawyer
she is Co vice-chair of the pan-african
reparations coalition in Europe as a
descendant of it as a descendant of
Africans enslaved in the Caribbean her
activism seeks to remember the historic
and cultural ties between diaspora
communities and their African motherland
thank you my thesis I have three main
arguments that reparations for slavery
are not just about the period of chattel
enslavement secondly that reparations
about are about much more than money and
thirdly that reparations are not a
divisive issue that they are the only
approach that can transform our broken
societies the reason why we're talking
about why the West should pay
reparations for slavery is because the
conversations of our Arab enslavement
and their responsibilities and the
complicity of some African collaborators
is already taking place so when I talk
about the West paying our first of all
like to clarify but when I refer to the
rest I'm referring to the conceptual
West which is the elitist construct of
euro American elites or the oligarchy
secondly when I argue that the West
should pay I'm referring to the notion
of payment as taking responsibility for
wrongs committed and harms inflicted and
by this I mean that the Western
establishment should take collective
responsibility for meeting the repair
Ettore justice needs of African heritage
communities and indigenous peoples who
were subjected to the criminality of the
crimes of genocide and ecocide which
collectively constitute the moranga meze
a kiswahili term meaning the african
hello host or African Holocaust and
continuum of chattel colonial and
neo-colonial Falls of in flavor Kelly
it's about providing or redistributed
wealth and resources that have been
gained by unjust enrichment and have
left a legacy of on just impoverishment
for the descendants of the African
enslaved people in 2001 at the world
conference against racism that was held
in South Africa it reaffirmed
fundamental human rights of people of
African descent particularly the right
to be repaired from criminal and
injurious acts of one's government in
the official outcome document of the
conference the governmental delegates
declared that the so called
transatlantic slave trade slavery
apartheid and colonialism were crimes
against humanity further that there was
an economic basis to these crimes that
are evident today in the injuring
nations that are wealthy and also the
impoverishment of much of the global
South and those of us who are from those
communities originally from the global
south the Durban Declaration also
declared that the effects and the
persistence of these structures and
practices have been among the factors
contributing to lasting social and
economic inequalities poverty on the
development marginalization and social
exclusion in many parts of the world
today and even further that there is an
obligation on the part of those nations
that were criminally enriched by these
crimes that they should engage in
redress secondly my argument is that
reparations for chattel enslavement is
not just about the period of chattel
enslavement in fact in 2001 Human Rights
Watch helpfully expounded when
addressing relatively old wrongs we
would base clay
of reparations not on the past abuses of
chattel enslavement itself but on its
contemporary effects that is we would
focus on people who can reasonably claim
but today they personally suffer the
effects of past human rights violations
through continuing economic or social
deprivation and when it comes to the
matter of crimes against humanity the
right to reparations does not get
extinguished with the death of the
original victims but can be pursued by
his or her heirs
hence why we in tarp oh the pan-african
reparations coalition I represent
initiated the stopped amalgam easy
we charge genocide ecocide campaign
which was inspired by the holistic and
historic call of Africans in America
under the auspices of the Civil Rights
Congress of the USA in 1951 who sought
to bring the United States government to
account for the crimes of genocide
against African people in America even
under traditional human rights law and
policy it is expected that governments
that practice or tolerate systemic
structural and institutionalized anti
black African prejudice and racial
discrimination and its specific form of
a free phobia that they should actually
compensate the victims and certainly
bring about an end to this condition so
reparations are about much more than
money if we go to the root of the term
reparations in Latin it is rep array and
that is basically about renewing and
transforming and it's for actual the
instance of making amends if we know to
international law the premise for
reparations was laid out in the chozo
factory case of 1928 which is that
reparation must as far as possible work
out all the consequences of the illegal
and re-establish the situation which
would in all of property bility have
existed if that act has not been
committed and so under the basic
principles and guidelines on the right
to a remedy and reparation for victims
of gross violations of international
human rights law and serious violations
of international humanitarian law it is
recognized that reparations consists of
measures of cessation assurances and
guarantees of non-repetition restitution
and voluntary forms of repatriation
compensation rehabilitation and measures
of satisfaction which are about looking
at moral damage emotional injury
intergenerational trauma mental
suffering and the injury to reparations
to sari ones reputation so reparations
are not a divisive issue they are the
only approach that can transform our
broken and divided societies according
to the same United Nations guidelines on
reparations an essential aspect of
reparations include an opportunity for
victims and in international law the
descendants of the enslaved are
classified as victims not in the way
that we use it in popular speak but it
means that we have a right to claim a
remedy and be recognized in law so
victims have a right to speak in a
public forum about their experiences and
to have an active involvement in the
reparative process the stop the
manganese II campaign and the 18,000
plus people that have steins to stop the
manganese II petition urge that there is
a need for dialogue between British
state and society and the way in which
this dialogue can happen is by
establishing the all-party parliamentary
commission of inquiry for truth and
repair Ettore justice which has terms of
reference including examining the dujour
and the facto racial and economic
discrimination which impact people of
African descent today and to look at the
impact of historic enslavement on
African descendant communities as well
as to make recommendations to Parliament
and other similar bodies on how best to
repair the legacies of enslavement and
colonization today we in bestop the
merengue music campaign believe that
establishing this all-party
parliamentary commission of inquiry will
go a long way towards institutionalizing
a reparative truth-seeking process that
will contribute to healing and restoring
the descendants of the enslaved and
facilitating racial justice and equity
between the descendants of the enslaved
as well as the enslavers today and of
course in wider society however such
repair of the relationship between
people of African descent and the rest
of society cannot take place without
public acknowledgement of the crimes
against African people and their
descendants over five centuries and
Counting and without UK governmental
action to enable redress and reparation
for the brutal injustice is committed
not only in the past but which still
continue into the present that is my
case the West should pay reparations for
slavery by taking responsibility for
living up to their declarations of
respecting human rights and the rule of
law
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Esther and our final speaker
against the motion is Tony sue L he's an
educational consultant and CEO of the
charity generating genius and helped set
up the science maths and IT Center at
Jamaica's University of the West Indies
he is author of black masculinity and
schooling how black boys survive modern
schooling and he was born in London to
Jamaican immigrants he is a descendant
of enslaved Africans yes I hope
hopefully you give both sides the right
amount of applause because I'm very
sensitive to what happens here look I'm
not I do this in a different angle I
want to argue that reparations is
actually a regressive step for black
majority countries and black individuals
and I say that in generic sense and
because it mainly gives too much power
and agency actually to white people I
actually think that the arguments placed
before just before is that they're
actually a bit too soft I I think they
need to go further and and I think in
some ways I mean well maybe I go further
I mean in terms of really what I suppose
we could talk about the agency and power
of black people themselves and what they
bring to this and if you look at the
leaders Boxey Washington Malcolm X the
Black Power movement Maya Angelou Oprah
and the key figure here is Marcus Garvey
that the father if you like the father
figure of pan-africanism not really
interested in reparations really and if
you look at their work what they're
actually arguing for is something
completely opposite in fact they're
arguing for in fact they see as a kind
of way in which it's a continual kind of
step backwards because white people are
there and we're begging for some money
the father of black nationalism Marcus
Garvey argues that slavery was a mere
interruption now you might say well
that's a bit harsh I mean in the sense
that all of what was explained and all
the horror of slavery and he says it's a
mere interruption and what he actually
means is that look there was a great
history for black people and a great
dignity before slavery this thing came
along
however we actually almost redeemed
ourselves even inside slavery we were
doing that reparation work already on
ourselves on ourselves and I think
that's the issue and I think that so he
wants Africa and he wants a new Africa
and he wants a new kind of sense of
identity in Africa and he sees that as a
new world built by black people built by
Africans themselves not with the money
of white people not with the guilt money
but because they can do it themselves
and he bases these three things he bases
it on three things
self-reliance so it wasn't surprising
that so many Jamaicans and my ancestors
were enslaved but they ran off the they
actually rebelled and ran away into the
hills and starts you to do the repair
job on themselves yeah Africa as a site
for opportunity not as this brokedown
place that we have to kind of give money
to and we are and all the kinds of
notions we have about Africa all the
negative notions I actually think some
of the reparations debate and the people
who support it add to that add to that
negativity and of course the notion of
success bloody Hill when you hear these
people talking about the state of black
people you just feel like you want to go
around gaion sort of hang yourself or
something that's so depressing it's so
[ __ ] depressing and I think that
really we want to see I see myself as a
successful black man I see myself as a
positive black man a CMOS and I see
black women in terms of a positive
future
and I think that one of the things that
that the great African leaders that I
see the Garvey is the Oprah Z of Maya
Angelou's can come to this in a way that
is completely different and a different
mindset at this and in fact it almost is
in line with holding us back um
Oprah let's just give one example Oprah
says once she has in a hallway of
Winfrey a picture of a woman who's just
been emancipated from slavery and she's
looking out and she's to the new world
and she says she remembers what my
Angelou said to her Mary Andrew says
this baby your crown has been paid for
so put it on your head and wear it in
other words my ancestors have already
done with the hard work they've already
done with the reparations yeah but
Marnie makes a beautiful song we talks
about the whole idea of the songs that
he's creators have been Redemption songs
and people don't really they sing that
song I don't really understand what he's
saying what he's really saying is look
we Jamaicans we've already unpacked it
for ourselves
the the the the the the vase that was
broken and then we had to put it back
together in all different bits but we
put it back together even though it
wasn't the same we put it back together
creatively and we created a new culture
and we created a new music and we
created a new identity right inside
slavery so we don't need white people to
come along and give us anything let me
ask you a question let me just give you
some quotes this is Garvey and uses the
word Negro because night in 1920s that
was the word that they used to describe
that he says the Negro would have to
build his own industry art science
literature and cultures before the world
will stop to consider him so what he's
talking about there is this
self-reliance this power of building
yourself not waiting around until white
people decide to give you something
he also says this we are going to
emancipate ourselves from mental slavery
remember we are not you like we are yeah
we are going to emancipate ourselves
from mental slavery because whilst
others might free the body none but
ourselves can free the mind and he goes
on again at the end he says our success
this is why I talk about the happiness
bit in this our success educationally
industrially and politically it's based
upon the protection of a nation founded
by ourselves and that nation could be
nowhere else but in Africa let me ask
you a question which country and we've
heard all the things about Africa being
in a bad way at a moment which country
in Africa at the moment is where the
fastest-growing has the fast one of the
fastest growing economies can you name
the country coming tell me which one
which one Kenya
hmmm not really nearly the I'll tell you
which one it is and this is this is the
one that is surprising it's Ethiopia
here is the country remember band-aid
remember that that the little children
down there with the Flies around them
and remember you having to pour in all
that that money into Ethiopia and really
and truly the outcome of all that money
went nowhere
Ethiopia and I just quote this is
predicted to grow by 8.5% this year this
is no kind of country little country
there with with little mud huts and kids
flying around this is a serious country
now why is it and an issue is it's not
about reparations
it's about investment what's happened is
Ethiopia has decided right here are the
terms were between the West than us
what's going to happen now and it's been
the Chinese that's understood this the
best is that you can come and invest in
us an investment means you're a real
person then because you get something
out of it we get something out of it
and we're grown-ups now and that's the
model for Africa and that's the model
for us also psychologically as well you
talk about the issue of the
psychological problems around slavery
and what it's done to to black people
one of the biggest issues I find I run a
charity called generating genius believe
that almighty one of my kids are black a
lot of my kids have come to me in terms
of my program really not going for much
and then ending up doing in the top
companies in it doing in Sciences and
simply all I've said to them is forget
all the negative kind of things said
about you not only about in terms of the
racism but also in terms of other black
people saying you can't do it because
you're black or because white people
have to give you reparations have to
allow you to do it before you can be
successful so when I'm arguing today my
argument is a different kind of angle on
this is that I think that part of the
problem we're facing is actually within
our own community directly to black
communities here part of I'm from in
certain terms of seeing ourselves
totally as victims Ethiopia that kind of
brought that country know everybody
wanted to give if I think now there are
Ethiopians ready now getting their food
parcels ready to sent to Sunderland yeah
help them out yeah that's where Africa
is going and so I would argue here that
in terms of the West the West should
invest because Africa and black people
need that investment because they're
worthy of it and they're worthy of it in
terms of this that their sense of
dignity and in terms of their their
sense that they're going to go somewhere
so my argument is please vote for me
thank you thank you Tony now I'm going
to move on to taking some questions from
the audience so there will be Usher's
walking around anybody that has
questions for the panelists please raise
your hand and the ushers will come to
you I'll take them in groups of three
that my question sort of in two parts
for the gentleman who just spoke last
you made great emphasis on Ethiopia
being this benchmark for Africa but I
think it's quite widely known that
Ethiopia was one of the only countries
that wasn't invaded as part of the
slaves so in in colonialism sorry and
secondly you mentioned the Chinese
coming in with business opportunities
that is also fused as a second wave of
colonialism first for some African
countries okay number one up here thank
you yes mr. c1 as well you talked about
black people not being given anything
but again it's widely known that's
particularly in the u.s. at the same
time when black people were not given 40
acres and a mule millions of land were
given to white people also they were
given loans cheap loans they were given
college education the advancement made
by a lot of white people was because of
what they were given so the question is
why is it everybody else must be given
but not black people and also the fact I
come from Trinidad partly Indo
Trinidadian as well I can be Indian
indentured laborers were given land at
the end of the internship again the
blacks were the only ones not given so
I'd love to hear your perspectives
[Applause]
and let's go to this lady here number
two thank you so forgetting the
emotional calls for reparations or the
reasons why one can repair oneself if I
owe Vodafone money and that when they
come to my house they don't come just
for exactly what was owed to them they
come and they can take my television
they can take whatever they want out of
the house there are laws in this country
there are laws in the US as well if
people were working without being paid
and it is owed the work of their hands
is owed to them it was very easy to
calculate what reparations were owned to
some owed to slave owners after their
property was taking for them I don't
understand why it's more complicated to
calculate what is owed to people when
there were many things including their
lives that we're taking from them
as well if that is easy to calculate
then it's not it shouldn't be that hard
to calculate what the difference is you
talked about the land that was given in
Georgia and you talked about studies
that were done about what happened to
the people many years after the land was
given and how many of them have not
become the richest families in that area
first of all Atlanta is one of the
richest areas in the u.s. particularly
for people of color and the second piece
of that is that was Jim Crow taken into
into was that considered when they were
calculating what had happened to people
after was the policing system in the
u.s. were systems in place in the US
where they would go and take the richest
black communities and bring them down
was that taken into consideration thank
you
so I'm gonna stop with those three
questions come to the panelists and
discuss them the first one was directed
to Tony
so yes Ethiopia the only African country
not to be colonized and then the second
part of that question that this Chinese
involvement that he speaks so highly of
is seen by many as a second wave of
colonialism yeah I mean Ethiopia is one
Kenya's and other ganas another I mean I
just picked that as an example I'm so
and Kenya certainly did have colonialism
and um what what I'm just saying is that
the model that is being used to sort of
almost kind of and it's very much in
line with what Garvey wanted in a sense
was that Africa is now seen as a serious
player on that on the planet and I think
that's the key and and that's really
what we're talking about is them what is
the difference what's going to make the
difference for the lives of those those
those young people in those countries
and how to move them on its investment
and I think that the share back China is
interesting because yes I'm look I have
no doubt about it the Chinese are trying
to do some ripoff or act here however if
you look at the amount of infrastructure
now in the Caribbean I live in Jamaica
and I'm just kind of at last we've got
some road systems you know which which
was just never there before when the
British were were engaging with us and
so I think that there is a there is a
deal going on here and part of the
problem and let me tell you one of the
problems that that whole Chinese
interaction with the Caribbean and
Africa I think Catherine did kind of
hint at this is that the deals are
brokered by those post-colonial leaders
and some of the backhanders and some of
the corruption that goes on is as much
as we've we've had in the colonial
period at the moment as I said just
we'll keep alluding to Jamaica but I
live there and our last year
94 billion Jamaican dollar so that's a
lot of money I suppose it you making
dollars that's not it might not be a
great what's a few billion
I've just got have just a little bit
lost in corruption and so I think that
that there is that to look at rather
than just see this as a as something
that a you know is a colonial thing and
a slavery thing I just think that we
should be thinking about how we manage
our own countries how it has grown ups
now in the region that we move on and we
want to move on not from reparations but
you want to move on with the investment
can I just say something about Trinidad
just quickly yes I've been trying to dad
lots of times and the young they made a
good point about what's happened there
but Trinidad has had a lot of oil which
is just completely wasted as well and
you know so you know one has to take
responsibilities of some of our actions
in the region and really kind of ask
ourselves some hard questions about what
we do with our resources I think it's
interesting you're saying the black
people should take responsibility but
the West should take no responsibility
for the situation which we find
ourselves do I appreciate that you have
a difficult argument to make I just
never thought I'd hear it made in that
manner
I mean Malcolm X Garvey but Malcolm X
actually says very clearly the self-help
is one thing we need self-help but we
have to understand the way we are in a
position where we've been wholly
disadvantaged and so in order for us to
help ourselves we need to be given what
we are oh it's simple isn't it and once
we are paid what we owed we will go away
and do exactly what we need to do so I'm
sorry X Garvey the Black Power movement
this is where reparations comes from the
debate so to invoke them is just as I'm
sorry it's a kind of madness and also
look I I would like to say that Africa
is rising there is this whole logic but
it's unfortunate
not true GDP is the very worst way to
measure improvement
the reason ppl pH D D so the reason
ethiopia CDP is 8.5 percent is because
of chinese investment right china puts
money in however do you know that when
China puts his infrastructure money in
about 85 percent of it goes to China
so actually ethiop is spending his own
money to pay China to build his roads
and you can be a good thing every day in
fact unfortunate you look positive
thinking is a good idea but you can't
delude yourself into believing that the
situation is better than the unfortunate
reality is if you actually look at the
situation in Africa Africa is kind of
the only continent that is going
backwards it really is and this is
unfortunate to the population of Africa
is going to probably treble record
Drupal minutes hundred years the
estimates from the World Bank needs a
recent estimates say that by 2050 nine
out of ten people who live in extreme
poverty will live on the African
continent the growth which you are so
celebrating this growth which only helps
the elite and only help the Chinese and
only helps a wisk it is not growth
slightly that helps Africa and when you
talk about investment
this is reparations actually is African
needs investment deserves investment
should have investment because the West
is in a major day and we should use the
investment properly thank you
[Applause]
so the next question was directed to you
as well Tony I think some of it's been
covered in what we've just discussed but
we can touch on it briefly so in the
u.s. white people descendants of
Europeans benefitted from educational
advantages that they were given many
advantages that they were given
education or professional etc how do you
respond to that
given that the argument you make is that
black people are not deserving of being
given any of those advantages well I
mean I don't actually understand really
what what I mean we're not denying here
that the injustice is took place in it
and that slavery was an atrocity I mean
no one's even thinking about that I mean
not you know as a real issue I mean as
Katherine said you know we don't it's
not that I think this is where the
argument seems to be that you think that
you're looking at the table now thinking
these lot here kind of in trying in some
way trying to kind of support or kind of
defend anything like that I mean an
injustice is an injustice and so all I
can say is I agree you know that's an
injustice yeah and then to the second
part of the question which Katherine it
was based on some of the points that you
made how do you black people the
descendants of African slaves catch up
with the advantages that have been given
to every other racial group okay so it's
important to just say as well of course
there have been advantages of course you
know when we say why weren't blacks
given anything well because that that's
the history I mean nobody's saying that
was right right you know nobody's saying
that that that blacks haven't had a hard
time this idea of what is owed to us
what don't mean people of African
descent yes when we say what is owed to
them
we aren't them right the the these
people are no longer with us
we the problem is is that identity
politics it forces us to see everyone in
a particular group as opposed to seeing
people as individuals
and as I was saying you know the child
of a rapist should not have to carry the
burden of his father's crimes it's
important to recognize that people are
individuals and those individuals are
responsible for the things that they do
but and how does one account for other
groups who are perceived as groups being
given certain advance so it was unfair
there's no question that percent catch
up with those advantages would either
would anyone on the what well interface
am i catching on I mean I'm I'm one for
talking about education you know I'm a
headmistress I believe very much in the
power of education I believe that if we
were able to give all of our children an
excellent education that individuals
born into poverty can change their stars
they're currently in the world 20
million slaves it is bizarre that we are
talking about slavery from hundreds of
years ago when right now in this world
there are 20 million slaves from North
Korea to India gender mistreatment of
women across the across various
countries well we don't talk about Hindi
spoke very specifically about the legacy
that enjoys to this day and how this
amount of money was only paid off in
2015 and how we very much live with the
afterlife of slavery would you like to
respond to this in any way Esther okay
for me this red herring of saying that
while every society had slavery and so
we don't have to deal with it it's very
problematic we're talking about a
specific experience that happened to a
group and I'm talking as somebody who
claims that African identity that has
been denied me and many others and many
of us who are you know risk that's part
of the restitution which is a principle
of reparations so we have to redefine
the languages that we use and stop
infusing Eurocentric ideas and
perspectives into essentially what is an
issue
about us as African people okay and we
need to have probably to justice in the
way that we even talk about our
ancestors our ancestors lived through us
this is not an academic debate from
above okay we are that we are then and
that is why some of us are raised and
this time to continue the struggle that
they began every successive generation
of African people from the beginning of
chattel enslavement in the 1400s has
championed reparations and I explained
what reparations mean in international
law you cannot reduce reparations to
money and compensation so those that
resisted enslavement they were seeking
their freedom which was restitution of
their dignity their humanity and their
right to be free their right to go to
their homelands and well what what would
you say to Tony's argument that this
approach is unhelpful and then it keeps
black people locked in a sort of victim
mentality because I think I think I
think I want it higher this is this idea
that you know the people who are is this
an individual thing and the criminals
aren't here anymore
that's absolutely in the UK we have what
we call the proceeds of crime pack if
you if you profit from a crime if my dad
products of a crime I guarantee you
government a their money from me and
that's what we're talking about
okay the slavers aren't here but their
profits are here and they are the things
which are benefitting the others
I know in our disadvantaging on all
right so when you were saying that the
idea that reparations is negative I'm
looking at sister Esther reparations
activists some of the most active people
in the community today around the issue
of reparations is simply nonsense and a
court quite offensive what's being said
is this damage has been done to all
restitution is old and when we get this
restitution go go and do what we like
nobody's asking for white approval they
be saying we should get paid can I come
in here
I think I think that that's the problem
that in fact we're waiting but rivers of
Babylon we're waiting and we're weeping
down there until somebody to white
people come and save us
now what what I'm arguing for is that
what I'm arguing for is I share your
passion equally probably more for the
injustice is done to my ancestors but
when I when I when I look at what I see
in terms of Jamaica in terms of Trinidad
in terms of Ethiopia in Africa I don't
see a crushed people I don't see a
people who have been totally wiped out
because of slavery and in colonialism
I see a people really in a sense already
already you have had already been
inventing themselves resisting making
repairing themselves and also needing
now in a sense to kind of join the world
one of the things that when when my
ancestors came off of the plantation the
project really was this how do we how do
we join the world again how do we
reconnect because we've been cut off
from it over these years and that really
was was what was a mindset what's gone
wrong and I agree with Katherine here is
that a politics came along and you you
talk about the Black Power movement and
you talk about people like Marian
Angelou and Marcus Garvey and all these
other great black leaders they were not
talking about reparations in in in that
identity politics is what no what they
were talking about was the fact that
black people themselves could change the
world could have the resources could
have their self-reliance to move on now
you're talking about the fact that okay
we in order to move on we need X amount
of resource to do it yeah of course you
do need that but what but what the
relationship is is no longer one about
begging for this thing or asking
reparations in the past what it is is
actually saying invest in me now work
with me now because we can actually help
the world we can change the world
there's a much more positive way of
looking at it and I just think that the
idea that Africa is not going to be in
the future one of the greatest spaces on
the planet is not China it's not going
into Africa just just because it's there
there's they're great resources there
the people themselves and a resort and
resources of their resources are there I
would like to take two more questions
which I think we have time for
we started slightly late so we'll go
slightly over I'll come to this
gentleman here number one all right
first of all I appreciate y'all for
talking here so it's a tough tough
talking to approach especially when
you're in the again side thank you
first of all Catherine wanna approach
that a same analogy about the the
father's sins if a person you can't it's
not a it's not an excuse to say that
many people committed served slavery if
a murderer is caught you don't get off
scot-free because there are unsolved
murders you were held this autumn for
which you are no cop [ __ ] I think it's
interesting that we're talking about
this in the sense of investment and I
think it's a good idea we can day you
mentioned all these monuments they build
these universities look glorious and
they were built on bet the backs of
slaves this isn't a preparations this is
this is seed money and I would like
maybe you a reinvestment in the people
who invested in the countries that they
live in so that that's that's the second
point I think my main conserving can
concern when I came in here was was yes
this is the question is the question is
the question I don't know if I can do
reparations if it'll cause upheavals
fairness is very various is important
and fairness hasn't been given to to
black people who been affected by
slavery but if getting reparations will
mean that white people will feel like
they've been betrayed and then will have
on civil unrest is that something we
should concern about civil war unrest
thank you
we're really we're running out of time
so very the very last answer I'm gonna
come to a Hindi was what about the
argument which is one of the arguments
that those who are against reparations
make that this the the the process of
reparations could incise more social
unrest and could cause resentments with
the rice or with Weis interest groups
when people lose things they often get
upset but sometimes people have to lose
me and if that is what makes things
forever then you just have to accept
that people won't be happy about I mean
you can't I mean this is part of
with alarm of our politics is that we
have tried to keep everybody happy no
one was worried about keeping us happy
when they were enslaving those two three
hundred years or imprisoning doesn't
matter aids or the police shootings in
the streets so again what you often have
with these arguments is we're expected
to be morally superior it have these
crazy expectations that were not
expecting from the from the master if
you like the other thing I really want
to say about this is the question here
is should the West pay reparations and
it's actually very simple no this is not
complicate the West is we know what the
West is the West is very clearly defined
right he's directly contemporary the
West used a system of slavery which was
utterly based on race the idea is not
based on race is a complete offensive
fantasy I'm sorry there were other
systems of slavery the system of slavery
were talking about was based on the race
expectation of enslaved Africans this
enriched the West beyond all manner of
identity and you have already paid
reparations you paid them through slave
owners and this should make you mad and
burn inside and oh really
and it enter the question with if
somebody has before you can actually
calculate it so in America is estimated
it's about fifteen trillion dollars that
enslave our old you can go back and say
unpaid labor you can go back and say
distress etc etc what are these things
which are enshrined in international law
it is perfectly possible to come up with
a number and say the West should pay for
it because it's difficult to work out
how that happens that does not mean it
should not happen and the question
racing today is should it happen and of
course issue
[Applause]
on that note I'm gonna ask each of the
speaker's working in reverse order to
just take one minute to sum up their
position and then we'll have the results
of the vote so I'll start with you Tony
yeah I mean one minute I mean what my
argument is this is that I think that
it's really now about the discourse
around this then what I mean by this
course is the sense that what we are
looking at here is a situation where I
believe on a national basis and on an
individual basis that in fact the whole
notion of reparation this is actually
regressive because it doesn't recognize
three things it doesn't recognize this
this powerful tool of self-reliance that
we've used and we were using within
slavery as well to help us and we've
shifted to it to almost a victim
mentality
it doesn't realize Africa as a site for
opportunity because it always has to
position Africa as as sort of diminished
so that more money can be poured into it
and and and also the notion of success
that black people in themselves are
successful and can do and that the world
for them is a positive space it doesn't
want to do that it wants to continually
remind us and remind their young people
that the whole thing is a nightmare I
should jump in there because we're
seriously over time but thank you Esther
I'll come to you now if you could sum up
in one moment in one minute please sure
there is a debt owed but it's not just a
financial debt now we're also
recognizing an ecological debt and the
climate and ecological emergency were is
disproportionately impacting African
people in Africa and the African
Diaspora where there was chattel
enslavement and colonization reparations
under international law means full
repair it's holistic restitution
guarantees of non-repetition
compensation rehabilitation and
satisfaction and finally I'd just like
to say that ultimately the restitution
is about the restoration
of African self-determination African
sovereignty in this day and age a
hundred and one British corporations
control over 1 trillion worth of
Africa's key energy and Mineral
Resources this is not about what
happened yesterday
we can't do anything about that but we
can sure as hell stop the moranga measly
of today Kathleen if you could sum up in
one minute please yeah well I don't
think practically reparations can work I
think that if we continually talk about
reparations instead of thinking how to
uplift certain communities thinking
about education for instance and how
that can help and instead indulge in
victimhood which can it doesn't help
anyone it it isn't helpful and slavery
was a grave stain on our history but
there are 20 million slaves that exist
nowadays and I think we should be more
interested in bettering that situation
and bettering the lives of people who
are in difficulty in this country by
investing our time in programs and
education and so on to help them raise
up from the poor situations that they're
in thank you
I came day the last words with you I
just really want to emphasize that
nobody on this side of the table is
saying that we are victims and that we
were relying and waiting for white
people never I mean never have black
people in any situation even in slavery
done this we've always resisted we've
always moved we've always marched and
always tried to build a number of the
people who tell me incorrectly quoted
basically well I've been part of that
movement to do so right and what's being
said here is that we are going to
continue anyway and thus the one of the
most positive things about black history
is that we have done so even in these
appalling conditions but as Malcolm as
Malcolm says though the knife still in
our back and will still go on whether
the knife in our back or not but the
reparations argument is a recognition
that please take the knife out and it'll
make a whole lot easier for us to have
freedom
you